I'm Luis Metzger thanks for coming to
this event by bio captivate it's an
experiment that we're doing to sort of
examine and perhaps change the culture
of science and that's that's what bio
captivate which we're going to set up as
a non-profit is thinking of doing we
want to start conversations about how
the culture of biology has come to be
the way it has and what we might learn
from that and what we could change about
it and the reason we care so much about
this is that clearly the engineering of
biology is going to drive so many
changes in humanities experience of the
planet and if we're lucky the
improvement of our planet and the fixing
of some of the damage that we've done to
it but also it's going to greatly affect
every aspect of human life and and have
ethical implications and so in this time
when biological engineering and
biological research is so important it's
perhaps worthwhile to examine the
culture of biology and the culture of
science and think about you know how
does it how's it evolved and how can we
change it maybe for the better
so that we can make this biological
revolution more effective and and
benefit everyone so tonight we have a
panel called politics solidarity
activism and science and we're going to
specifically discuss with great
panelists some some aspects of the
culture of science as it intersects with
politics and activism and and hopefully
you know learn some things from each
other tonight and the other thing I'd
like to tell everyone is that this is
the first night that we've had all the
co-founders of bio captivate in one
place so I'm going to quickly ask them
to introduce themselves and after that
we'll go ahead and get started and we'll
introduce the panel so without further
ado Kiera havens hi folks thank you all
for being here
it's really wonderful to see kind of a
full house of folks interested in
interested in examining their
assumptions about what biotechnology is
what it's for who's supposed to be using
it how we ask the questions right
because we all operate in you know if
you read David Foster Wallace you know
kind of we live in the water right and
you don't really think about the water
until you choose to think about the
water so that's what bio captivate is
all about we're about helping you see
the water for what it is
and thinking about you know what how
does this impact our actions how does
this impact our decisions how does this
impact the way we choose the questions
that we investigate in science so I hope
as you listen to the panel tonight
you listen to your own responses and ask
yourself why is it that this thing hits
me there why is it that I respond in
this way to this assertion or this
assumption or this challenge right
because we all operate with these
unconscious biases of one kind or
another and just thinking about them
just opening the door to asking why is
it do I think this way huge step forward
and kinds of helps us have a better
conversation about what is going to be a
really influential and really impactful
technology my own personal background I
come from I guess I left the Church of
biotechnology a very long time ago right
there's maybe a tendency of scientists
to think that science if you just study
it long enough you'll find the solution
and these days I tend to think science
is a tool it's a part of the solution
but there are much broader much bigger
questions that are maybe better answered
by the humanities and so my interest is
in beautiful biotechnology and how do we
go about making good technologies which
have an impact that we want them to have
rather than an impact that we haven't
thought too much about so that's where I
come from that's why I'm involved in bio
captivate and I'll pass this along to
yan hi my name is Yin welcome everyone
and really happy other new faces on
faces and so my back rise inside
molecular biology but I a some part
discovered that in order to solve the
most pressing problems in science you
actually need to go outside like you
need to go into
networking or psychology or philosophy
etc so that's why I am here
that's um so there are great experts of
networking and psychology and political
science and there are great expert
understanding what the specific problem
science facing but the thing is we
create this well so to bring the two
together to apply the state of the our
networking skills and psychology and
political science to change the specific
pressing problems within science and
hopefully that also has gained into the
wider society thank you and then now I
pass the mic to Chris hi everybody I'm
Christopher Oakes so I'm a marine
biologist so I've always been thinking
about the water and I'm also super
interested in the business of biology
and though the work that I'm doing now
and the work that I've been interested
in all of my life it intersects with
politics and just public perception and
I think that as scientists we often are
not communicating as often and as
in-person as we should be it's often
about the problem-solving and and as it
you know the minutia and I think
gathering people together and talking
about bigger issues and and higher
dimensional thinking is really important
and we've got folks in this group that
get that and I'm really proud to be
supporting that so I'm happy to be a
part of bio captivated
so enjoy the panel Thanks
so I'd now like to introduce our
panelists and I'm really thankful for
the time they've taken to come here and
Mike one of our panelists also has
hosted us tonight so Mike thank you for
thank you for that yeah yeah it couldn't
couldn't get lost yeah so so first I'd
like to introduce goalie goalie has been
a transmitter of state-of-the-art
biotech lab techniques and thinking at
City College for 15 years and I identify
with this because in the wake of all
that we're learning about you know the
elite college scandals I also went to a
public undergrad university and think I
had a decent education there so there
was really good work being done in our
public universities in case anyone
doubts that and goli really has taken a
lot of time in her career to think about
the education of young scientists going
into biotech who maybe come from a
variety of different socioeconomic
backgrounds and I think her perspective
on that is going to be really important
tonight so welcome goli
Fatma is a return panelist we like so
much you know she's she's great she's
co-founder for Theron M which is a
company that is bringing nematode
pheromone technology to the market and
she's a scientist entrepreneur and she's
really interested in a number of
different aspects of Grants writing ship
for lack of a better word and sort of
the delicate dance of getting funding in
science and I think she can speak to
that tonight Christine who were really
excited to have here co-founded
two-photon art and it gives scientists a
way to express their love of science but
also in many ways the intersection of
science and and causes that they believe
in through you know messages like
science needs dreamers and
is political she's also the founder of
the stem squad which is an online
community for people in stem whose
genders have been marginalized and she's
a writer I urge you to read any of her
writings and I think she can provide
great perspective on the topics that we
have tonight and not least
Mike Mike Selden CEO and co-founder of
finless foods and his day job involves
growing healthy marine animal cells on
their own instead of live fish but he
has a background in biochemistry and
molecular biology he's spent a lot of
time and effort devoted to climate
justice and science advocacy and also
advocate advocacy for education
that's cognizant of people coming from
different socioeconomic backgrounds and
so again I think he'll have many useful
contributions to the panel tonight so
I'd like to get started with our
questions and I think you know one thing
that we might discuss and start off with
when thinking about science and politics
is each of your opinions about the
culture around scientists being
activists in one form or another and my
question for you is how do you think
that has gone in your experience what do
you think the expectations are in the
field of biology that you've been
involved in and I'm just curious what
your comments are about that and let's
start with you
goli scientists as activists so I guess
we've all taken some activists type of a
role in our careers and you know in some
form you know myself as as in biotech
instructor I guess I try to bring people
up and talking about equity and science
for all for all people not just the
elite but I think it's for scientists is
super important to communicate science
to everybody
and non-scientists when I was going to
school it was really not
it wasn't looked up people who did that
kind of stuff they weren't really looked
up to write that they went to the masses
and started talking about science
scientists was somebody who was in their
labs just doing their work and
publishing papers and not talking to
people not socializing and but I feel
like that that is changing in our
society and scientists are going out
they are going they are talking about
science and you know we have volunteers
going to middle schools they're going to
elementary schools to high schools going
to communities and and talking about
science and all the cool things that you
can do with science and just a quick
follow-up on that
have you observed the barriers barriers
to cultural barriers to scientists
feeling comfortable being activists in
that way yeah like I said and when I was
in school that was definitely a barrier
it wasn't it wasn't a good thing to do
right you you had to be in your lab
seriously working eleven twelve hours a
day and not really getting into events
like this it was not really something
that people did I think the barriers are
breaking it's getting better and better
and people are talking about science a
lot more so yeah there are still
barriers we still have work to do but it
it is improving Thank You Batman
science is an activist like she
mentioned when I was in grad school you
were expected to work day and night but
I was very lucky I had a PhD advisor who
didn't actually clock people in her note
out but I know some of the labs I my
decision was I was going to enjoy my PhD
and I was going to do it between 8:00 to
5:00 so I organized everything make the
plans and I knew what I was gonna do two
months earlier and I went to all of the
student clubs and I was in graduate
student council
so that's why I know many of the other
problems that were associated with the
graduate school and graduate students
and many of the positives and negatives
you hear but one of the other thing I
did in sciences I've been to many other
labs and training was actually quite
different in different labs and one of
the labs I've been to it was a very
productive lab and I actually worked a
lot less in that particular lab and I
got more papers out but they had this
really great protocols and everything I
did I learned something about it
and I really liked that strategy so when
I moved to my PhD lab and I still kept
in touch with them and I the way date
that science was very enlightening to me
and whether the experiment worked or not
I learned something I knew where I was
going and despite the hurdles I make
progress so I took that philosophy and
when I had students and I realized many
of the students undergrads do not get to
have that kind of training and I did
provide that kind of training to them
and once we were really interested many
of them actually went to medical school
the last one and I gave equal
opportunity doesn't really matter what
background they have and the last one I
trained I had a training grant she got
into Lewis Scott's temple Medical School
and she said the only reason she got in
there is because she worked with me and
all of the projects she taught during
the interview she told about those
projects and the only place actually she
got she did a lot of check marks you
know with the medical schools you have
to do a lot of check marks and many of
the laughs she did didn't actually
provide her actual research experience
and the only place she actually got to
do research and how to do research was
my lab and I thought I'm very proud of
her and she got into the medical school
and I believe
she's gonna make a great doctor yeah so
so that's true
so Fatma you're sort of describing a
great culture and did you feel that
freedom to have activism came out of
that culture or did you feel in those
programs that you were sort of stymied
by an expectation that a scientist only
discusses science and not you know
political things that might affect
science political things that affect
science now you have to be careful
needed science and what you say you
don't want to piss off people because
that might affect your publication if
you're going to publish and that might
affect your future job so one of the
things when I wasn't got into grad
school one of my advisor said it's not
about just intelligence to get PhD you
need to learn the politics and how to
navigate the system so I think depending
on the location and until you get a
graduate degree and the to graduate
student in one of the labs I've been to
said
Padma you can do earth-shaking things
when you do have your PhD during your
postdoc with the PhD just learn how to
do science and I've been to both places
and I think that was one of the best
advice I got I actually my PhD research
I didn't really select any earth-shaking
things but it turned out that it got
into the textbooks within less than 10
years I think five or six years after I
published it but the politics I don't
really know what to say you still need
to be careful about what you say you
don't really want to offend
so so that you know that's actually
really helpful perspective because I
don't think people realize how there is
this unspoken culture of being careful
what you say outside the laboratory and
you know Christine actually has built a
business and a brand around scientists
saying things outside the laboratory so
I'm curious what you think about this
so definitely everything that fama said
is true about having to be super careful
about what you say about politics and
even at Berkeley so I'm currently a grad
student and in neuroscience getting my
PhD at Berkeley and I thought I should
be able to express myself politically
here it's Berkeley
it's neuroscience but that was not the
case I had a lot of people telling me
that I was gonna you know I should stop
talking about politics especially after
Trump was elected if I wanted to have a
scientific career and at that point I
decided honestly it's not really worth
it to have a scientific career if I have
to shut up about all the things I care
about immigration gender equity housing
rights all this stuff like this is stuff
that I care about as a human and I was
not willing to decide between being
myself as a human and an activist and
being a scientist so I got into a lot of
difficult conversations and there's
definitely a dichotomy I think people
really do uphold this idea that you do
have to choose between being part of
society and being an objective scientist
and observing society so there is this
idea that in order to be truly objective
you should not be a full participant in
society and this was a really difficult
thing especially in the first-ever March
for science which was about three years
ago to the day almost it was Earth Day
2017 oh I guess two years ago after
Trump got elected you know a lot of
scientists were very energized mostly by
the idea that our funding was going to
taken away from us unfortunately but a
lot of scientists were galvanized and
the March for science was originally I
think the idea and the leadership was
was predominantly from one perspective
predominantly white and male and so
there was this effort to represent more
diverse voices but that had a lot a lot
of pushback from scientists and they
really felt that putting forth black
woman putting forth undocumented people
putting forth environmentalist even was
not objective as if the the way to
observe and do proper science was the
was the way that had been done for
centuries which is extremely problematic
like we don't have proper representation
and in our subjects for medical studies
so people didn't understand like the
heart attack symptoms for women because
we only studied men and a lot of the
what we know about how diseases affect
people is not really how diseases affect
everyone is how diseases affect white
people in North America and so this
whole idea that scientists are objective
only if they prescribe to the default
ideas that science has prescribed which
is usually you know one that is European
or North American there is a lot of
pushback and so I made this decision
that if I had to be this way and pretend
to be a white guy in order to be a
scientist I was not going to work for me
and I did not have even in Berkeley the
community where I could go to a bar and
have a conversation about how frustrated
fell by policy without having to engage
in you know the importance of free
speech and you know all the other like
buzzwords we have that we that are used
to silence diverse voices so I decided
you know I'm not gonna debate whether or
not scientists political anymore which
is a debate I got into a lot I was going
to make pins that just say science is
political I just gonna put that out
there and it turns out that so many
other scientists feel the exact same way
and and it is totally a thing where you
have to decide if you're gonna out
yourself as someone who believes that
science is political or that science
needs dreamers or undocumented people or
that we should fund different things in
science it is a decision out yourself
and so now like creating pins or
creating a way that people that can
scientists can express themselves as
someone who believes in these ideals has
kind of created a community of
scientists online that can find each
other and to know that we are people
that can trust each other to have these
conversations and just skip the barrier
of whether or not science is political
and just get right to how how scientists
can get involved in politics and improve
things so I'd still think it is very
difficult to be a scientist involved in
politics even at Berkeley but I think I
I do think it's getting a little bit
better otherwise I would not be here
today I would not have any presence I
still agree with absolutely everything
you just said and I do want to say
especially that like as somebody who
like very easily presents as white and
male we are seen as the objective voice
all the time and so it's our absolute
responsibility to talk about this [ __ ]
because people like who look not like me
which like no the other three of you
have a much harder time and like get
really like her ranked for stuff that I
can just say really easily and like as
somebody who like is a CEO has a company
is an entrepreneur and has if you know
me at all pretty extreme political
beliefs you can get away with that if
it's done in it for like respectful way
people who are like me are seen as like
the objective truth holders I totally
agree there is no objective anything
ever like no matter what even if you're
stating facts you're stating facts to
support something and like no matter how
you present any given story you're
having some sort of ideology affect that
and I think that that's actually really
important to consider in terms of like
the March for science specifically I
have literally like hours of critique on
the march of science I hate the March
for science as a scientist because the
March for science really really wants to
have this sort of idea of objectivity
and so what the March for science does
is it basically doesn't say anything
controversial more or less all the signs
the March for science
science is good no one disagrees with
that no one like even on the like right
they still think science they say
science is good right and so like saying
things like that challenge is nothing it
challenges no one and it means nothing
and so that's why at the March for
science like you know myself and like my
friends we all tried to sort of stir
[ __ ] I mean we're you know a lot of
people who can well some of us anyway
can like present white male like do
things like this but basically we were
you know more talking about like we were
trying to tie we're basically trying to
do sort of propaganda anyway were if you
just say like science is political over
and over again people start to believe
it
which i think is good we basically were
like tying things people believed and at
the March we're like science is good
vaccines work you know GMOs are good if
you're anti-nuclear you are a climate
science denial ists and just like tie
things together and like yeah not
everybody agreed with us but that's the
point the point of a March is not to
have everybody agree with you it's to
put forth a position that challenges
like the air quotes objective reality
and cuz people are like listening to
this so yeah 100% agree with all of that
and also like you know people like me
need to talk about that a lot more and
not leave it to people who actually
probably will face consequences for
saying things like that I would like to
add one of my undergraduate students
actually went to science policy I was
very happy about it so many in minute
directions knowing science is good for
her to work on it and that's a step and
the things that work for males not
necessarily work for women and my
approach is you create awareness because
we don't really want to have directly
defense because the minute we get
defense people shut down we want that
open mind so that's it might be a little
subtle but it is fairly effective but
the things you do and people may not
take it as offensive but if I do the
same thing they will take it very
offensive but we'd already want that
because we want to reach out so our
style is a little different
I have something to add too so yeah I
totally agree that talking about
politics maybe in science it's you know
there are barriers to that but we can
all do our share in our own little roles
so just little examples like learning a
little bit about bioethics so if you're
in you know in you know ahead of a lab
have your lab techs in your graduate
students and your postdocs have them
read a little bit about bioethics
if they're working with mammalians if
they're working with human cells where
did that's where did the cells come from
who did they belong to you know these
are the things and you need to start
thinking about or just little things
start recycling all those plastic that
we generate in our labs right little
things or encouraging hiring of you know
underrepresented people as lab techs and
students bringing students or
undocumented students to your lab so we
can all do our little share of you know
of activism Thanks those are really
great perspectives and I'd like to sort
of continue move on to a related topic
and this is scientists having activism
that affects them so I think that my
impression anyway has been that
scientists are discouraged or encouraged
to be dispassionate and and a step
removed from any issue that might affect
them directly and I would argue in fact
that that's one reason why for the work
that they do
scientists are relatively poorly paid
you know with regard to other
professions that require this amount of
education or work and to be clear I
think all professions are important but
I think scientists have done a very poor
job of advocating for themselves because
there is a culture in some quarters of
this dispassionate keeping a distance
from
from speaking out on issues that affect
the scientists themselves and one you
know one area that this is becoming
important in the bay area especially for
scientists is the rise of the cost of
housing and there's all these IPOs that
are coming in tech there will be a lag
phase but housing will increase in cost
and I was a group leader at a big pharma
company and I had to move around the Bay
Area several times just to find
somewhere where I could afford to live
and sleep at night so that I could be
productive during the day and I'm very
curious what the panelists think about
activism involving scientists themselves
and have they participated have you
participated in it do you know people
who have what are the issues that you
think that scientists should be saying
okay public this is getting in the way
of us doing our jobs and it's not
necessarily housing it can be numerous
things but I'd like to hear what you all
think about that the cost of living in
the Bay Area is a huge problem to be
honest with you I mean I teach at a
community college and I mean we we
encourage our students to do well and
you know go get a job great but you know
I know deep down that even when they do
get that job it's not going to pay much
and and I always wonder how do they
continue living in San Francisco you
know you know at age of 30 there's still
like living with five other people in
the same apartment so it's just not
practical it's definitely a big issue we
are really trying to encourage the and
then another thing is that if you know
you go all the way to PhD and then
you're still not able to afford a
housing that's really a huge problem but
we are trying to encourage the places
like UCSF or Genentech these big
employers to think about hiring people
who are not necessary
phd's and giving them these salaries so
that they can live and they can be
productive in their at their works but
it's it's a it's a very complicated
issue and yeah and difficult one yeah so
you know as somebody who runs a company
we have to pay people and they have to
in turn pay for housing and so it's
harder for us when people can't afford
housing we means we need to have like
higher salaries because like if you have
people who are commuting an hour and a
half to work because they have to live
extremely far away in order to afford it
they have to live with their parents
these are people who are stressed at
work these are people who like perform
worse and like have a worse time of
everything and you end up with lower
quality work so it means that you have
to pay people a lot more I mean I think
public housing should be a right
incredibly successful companies basic
companies God countries that's an awful
slip incredibly successful countries
have public housing people point to
Singapore as this like model of
capitalism this like beautiful city on
the hill its market based everything 80%
of those people live in public housing
that's government-funded free housing
for those people
that's what successful countries do
housing is a right not a commodity so in
terms of direct activism that's been
done around here I'm a I mean haven't
interactive anymore because I'm really
busy with finless but basically I still
am a card-carrying member of the
Democratic socialists of America so a
literal card-carrying socialist and then
in SF there was I was just trying to
remember what the hell it was called
because I didn't work on the campaign
but it's called prop F or sorry question
F and so basically this was a right that
s FD sa essentially made up the San
Francisco Democratic socialists it
passed and basically this new right
allows tenants to stay in their homes
and so what it does if you're being
evicted
it requires that your landlord give you
written notice in your own native
language whatever that is that you now
have the right to free counsel and then
we also got money allocated towards we
the
chapter come money allocated towards
this legal counsel so basically if
you're being evicted you have noticed
that you have access to slash the right
to a lawyer who can help you stay in
your housing and maybe keep something
that's rent controlled keep something
that's cheaper instead of getting
evicted the conversation in San
Francisco is one that is really sick
it's one that's sort of basically you
have young bees and NIMBYs more or less
you have people who refuse to build
housing and they're usually more
conservative and then you have like
Democrats who just sort of want
developers to do whatever they want
neither these are solutions we're not
going to get anywhere with this 20% of
the housing in San Francisco is still
empty a lot of these are investment
properties America has six times more
empty properties than it has homeless
people in this country this isn't a
supply problem this is like a problem
with people actually being able to
afford places to live and so we need
legislation that can actually get people
in housing keep people in housing pay
for housing build public housing stop
all the developers building developers
building these like gentrification
fortresses that only people like me can
afford and like it directly affects all
of us especially us as scientists
because these aren't just like some
weird like a hypothetical poor person I
mean these are like our co-workers these
are our colleagues at finless these are
people that I work with on a day-to-day
basis and so like it does directly
affect us housing is a really important
thing and we really need to basically
find a way to push for public housing
and so that's why SF DSA has tried to
build basically a Fibby movement public
housing in my backyard as a means of
trying to solve for this and actually
get like people in because if it gets
too much worse I mean none of us are
gonna have a workforce at all and like
all the things that you and I do on a
day to day basis you're not gonna be
able to do that anymore do you like
eating food your waiter or waitress has
to like live somewhere and like you're
going to have to pay more in order to
afford like where they live like this is
a thing that actually does affect
everything it's sort of like I mean
trickle-down is obviously done but
trickle up I don't know so anyway there
is a way to act to advocate for this I
do you know say there like if you're in
San Francisco the SF DSA does really
really amazing work on housing and
they're asked to actually plugged into a
bunch of other
groups that also do incredible work on
housing Eastbay less so this is a really
great question like I have just have so
many different points running through my
mind like starting from we as a society
view doing science as a privilege and so
we are willing to be underpaid for and
people don't advocate for a better pay
but also many scientists are like
generations like multi-generational like
the amount of PhD students who have PhD
parents is astounding so there is just
like a difference between the people who
do do science and the rest of the
population but also science is something
that people do move around a lot for I
mean we live in a tech a biotech biology
hub and like by having hubs we do
displace people and so there's just so
much to unpack here but yeah I think a
lot of what we have to consider is like
what is the worth of bringing scientists
all together in one place versus
displacing the people who are here I was
born in San Francisco in what is now
known as the Zuckerberg Hospital and
I've seen the city change a lot and I do
also want to take an opportunity to plug
safe organized spaces and st. francis
homelessness challenge which is led by
Amy Farrah Weiss who does a lot of work
for people who have been displaced like
something like 70% of homeless people in
San Francisco at one point did live in
homes in San Francisco so these are
people who are displaced so I think it
is a responsibility both for us as
scientists to advocate for better pay so
that people who do come from like low
socioeconomic status can enter and
sustain themselves in the scientific
workforce but also to think about like
what is the impact of when we do create
these amazing hubs for research and
science and technology what does the
impact of that like do we as CEOs or
whatever like how the responsibility to
try not to displace people who have
lived in these communities but rather
just build new places closer to where we
work you know there's just so much to
unpack in this and it's an amazing
question I think you could have a whole
panel just on this point
the housing prices that's really really
important one of the reason actually we
moved to Davis but besides it's an Ag
hub and we are an Ag biotech housing was
very expensive and it would be very
difficult for us and for the scientist I
think affordable housing should be
provided because if you're scientists
even if it is educated if they're
worried about how am I going to pay for
my rent you're not getting your
full-time half today this person's mind
is someplace else if you want that mind
in your work you might hire them for
cheap you think you're higher than for
Half Price
but half the time you're scientists mind
is someplace else so your scientist is
there part time physically full-time but
reality it's part time so if you want to
get full-time that are scientists or any
of the people who are working if you
want to get them full-time physically
and mentally you have to pay them the
proper salary that they can afford and
they don't have to worry about
month-to-month have their pain so I
totally agree that down everyone and
Mike Selden and his efforts so I can
provide a little perspective on this as
well when I was a postdoc at UCSF I
think at that time this typical salary
for a starting postdoc was 42 K or and
that was bad enough that we lived in
postdoc dorms and I was like how am I 29
years old what have I done wrong in life
that I'm 29 year old 29 years old and I
can hear people through the walls and I
have like a random roommate this is not
good
and what was also interesting about that
is that I was lucky because I I could
and I eventually did say screw this i'ma
start applying for industry jobs which
is what I wanted to do anyway I was
fortunate enough to you know leave after
not very long in that situation however
one thing that I noticed that I really
think should be discussed because it's a
social justice issue is the hiring of
foreign postdocs on visas and I was at a
conference a few years ago where a very
productive professor in the structural
biology space I was asked at a cocktail
hour how did he get so much work out of
his small group of postdocs and without
even pausing he said oh well I only hire
foreign postdocs and I make sure they
have families and they know that if I
fire them they and their families have
to vacate the country in short order so
he said it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter how much I pay them so I mean to
be fair to most of the faculty I don't
think that many of them explicitly do
this but the fact that this is even as a
strategy or a structurally possible is
something that really needs to change in
in the culture of how we do big research
so I thought that that insight for those
of you that weren't aware of that that
sort of thing goes on so you know the
structure of our of how we do big
science is sometimes fundamentally
exploitative and one thing that bio
captivate can do hopefully over time and
with connections that you make with each
other tonight and other evenings in the
future I hope is address you know how
can we change the culture how can we
change the incentives you know the drive
the sort of thing like hiring postdocs
and then threatening to the deport them
or fire them and have them deported and
the irony in all of this is that UCSF
gave us postdoc appreciation days when I
was there and we got a free t-shirt and
like and and food and you know to this
day I will do I will eat any free food
as long as it's like not overtly spoiled
so this is what the scientific education
does to you but anyway next topic so I
think many you know the people on this
panel have a variety of backgrounds and
I think one thing that's discuss
in science inevitably as education
because education or training those two
are not necessarily the same thing but
these there are long educational and
training routes in science and
historically there have been limitations
in industry at least big big pharma is
one example where volition in science is
restricted to people who have earned a
PhD
sometimes restricted to people who've
earned a PhD and done a postdoc perhaps
that's changing and one thing that I
wanted to ask the panelists about is
what is their opinion of science
education in the context of should we be
advocating for something different or
what changes would you advocate for if
you were going to advocate for changes
in how we educate scientists and whether
we even need to formally educate
scientists as far as we do in all
circumstances yeah I mean so at City
College of San Francisco we I would say
50% of our students already have a
bachelor degree but they come to us some
of them their bachelor degree is in
completely different fields but some of
them have bachelor degrees in biology
and chemistry we've had even master's
people new people who have master's
degree but they come to us because they
know all the theory they can tell you
all about how cells work but they're not
able to work in a laboratory
they've never touched a pipette in their
whole four years of education they've
never designed an experiment they never
had two reports you know and do data
analysis and you know give a PowerPoint
presentation so that's why they come to
us they come back to Community College
after graduating from UC Berkeley and UC
Davis and UC Santa Cruz and they come to
us because they need to learn the
hands-on how do I work in a laboratory
so that's something that needs to be
changed of course that would be bad for
us but that's definitely something that
needs to be changed you get a bachelor
degree you should be able to
you work in a laboratory but to advocate
for people who don't have formal degrees
that's something that we do as City
College all the time because the other
50% of our students don't have a degree
and we take students who are going
through other career changes or for
whatever reason that we're not able to
finish their college education and so
they're now that they're older and most
of them are most of them are in their
late 20s early 30s they have families
they have responsibilities they have
jobs but they are at the point in their
life that they wanted they have always
been interested in science and now they
feel like I want to do this I want to do
science it's difficult right and and
they don't want to go get a four-year
degree but with just a little bit of
training maybe they won't be PhD level
but they will be able to do you know
your lab tasks there's a lab technician
and still contributes to an important
research project and so we should
encourage all companies to think about
hiring non PhDs and even non bachelors
as their technicians if they have the
skills and they can do it
there's no needs really for that for
your degree for it thank you
one thing that I've learned in hiring
over the years that speaks to what what
you've observed is that the best
predictor of a good employee is whether
they can learn new things quickly and
they're enthusiastic and whether they
have a certain skill set sometimes
matters but usually it's it's the former
that's more important so we wanted to
comment it's this this question is
really interesting because as a current
PhD student there are a lot of people I
know who want to go into industry but
oftentimes when you graduate with a PhD
and get an industry job you just start
out at entry-level anyway so it's as if
the PhD
also doesn't matter I mean you get might
get paid more but your ranking is as low
because a lot of I think industry
employers recognize that like it's great
if you have a PhD but that doesn't
necessarily mean that any of your skills
or knowledge like your dissertation
might not have any direct relevance to
the work at hand and I also believe that
you can basically teach anyone anything
but it's the willingness and the the
ease at which someone can learn
something that makes someone you know
really great asset to whatever they're
contributing to so I firmly do not
believe that there's necessarily any
like strict correlation between
someone's worth and the degrees that
they've earned
but we certainly uphold that and I think
a lot of it might be due to an incentive
of people with PhDs to uphold this
hierarchy and like honestly there is
potentially way more PhDs than then
there are jobs that pay people
accordingly based on the amount of time
they've sunk into their education and
training and I don't think that what
we're doing necessary right now is
working but like it's so difficult to
imagine a system changing in which where
we already have maybe too many
overqualified people yes I I know I'm
coming from this perspective where
people constantly do tell us that we
might be overqualified which is so
hearing this question is kind of
interesting
Oh qualification I have something to say
about it so when I had my postdoc and
when I was actually looking for
physicians it's over qualification for
the PhDs science education is important
over qualification for PhDs they usually
say oh maybe should I remove it from my
PhD would it help me my decision was no
I'm not removing my PhD or postdoc this
is what I did and here are the things
what I can do for the science education
wise I think everyone should have right
to have a good science education because
it has benefits that undergraduate
education may not be able to give
same thing PhD and it gives us the
analytical thinking when you look at
things you look at it differently and it
gives so many different skill set that
you can use it in many other places and
and actually if I could pivot this
question just a little bit based on
where the answers have gone what do we
do with this pool of overqualified or
excessive PhDs
I mean it's a problem that I've thought
a lot of about because as the biological
economy grows those skills and that
creativity that those people hold in and
and bring with them wherever they go
those can be used those can be used to
drive a great counterculture
okay it could be used to great to drive
entrepreneurialism can be used to drive
a lot of good for society and you know
I'm curious and I'll start with Mike
what what ideas we might have for sort
of draining this huge pool of
postdoctoral fellows out of the
University and into other opportunities
and I should also note that we're going
a little over on the time for the main
panel before we go to questions and
answers so if no one objects I might cut
the question section shorter and we can
all catch up during the happy hour and
sort of dig into this issue because it's
really central to the economy of science
I think
[Music]
yeah I mean I think you know Lois you
and I have like butted heads on this
mildly in the past you know you're
servicing like what do we do with these
PhDs how do we drain them out of
academia and how do we put them into
private industry and my answer is don't
I really think that you know real
research happens in the public sector
and like when the public sector is well
funded things happen that actually
benefit everybody and like there is a
lot of use for that you know like my
family's from the Soviet Union like it's
one of the like fastest rates of
industrialization that's ever happened
and my grandma has a PhD in physics and
like she loved that and people here just
like how does your grandma have a PhD in
physics like is she some sort of like
wild feminist I'm like no no no she is
not she's very regressive in like a
million awful ways but yeah she's
awesome she's very smart but like you
know voted for Trump but she doesn't
speak English doesn't matter but she and
I love her very much but yeah I mean
like you know she's like everyone got a
PhD that's what you did and like you got
to work you were an engineer you were a
physicist you built public knowledge and
so like if we actually fund that
properly we can create way more
innovation than we ever can i heavily
recommend there's a documentary it's
called the smart state it is amazing and
basically it talks about like we talked
about innovation in the private sector a
lot and like everyone's like oh well you
you know you hate private industry or
whatever but you use an iPhone first of
all I use a samsung because I hate
myself and second all of that technology
came from the public sector as Steve
Jobs put it in a nice little box but
like the GPS the touchscreen the
processor these are not things designed
by Apple these are not things invented
by Apple these are things invented by
people doing PhDs in the public sector
and so for me I'm just like fun the crap
out of that there's a ton of work that
still needs to be done we clearly have a
lot of technology that we haven't
figured out yet having is something
that's like publicly available and done
in a very like meticulous way I think is
hugely advantageous and like yeah
there's definitely ways we can
incentivize entrepreneurship and stuff
like that I think entrepreneurship has
its place but I think that in America we
have a really big funding problem and we
should fix that first so
not to start a debate no no actually I
agree I agree I do wonder though if
we're going to continue funding science
the way that we do we make universities
behave more like universities and less
like businesses in terms of converting
grad students and postdocs hours into
papers which get grants which then turn
into a hundred percent overhead which
hires administrators and maybe you don't
need that many administrators as we have
in many universities so maybe there's a
regulatory aspect to educating
scientists or maybe even a bill of
rights for science trainees is something
that could have value but I would say
that I I'm not in favor of abolishing or
even reducing public funding of science
I've just seen that universities are not
set up to discover a therapeutic drug
they just aren't their press releases
forget about them they are not set up
for drug discovery and and design and
optimization for instance nor are they
set up for industrial production most of
the time so I view there the symbiosis
between academic science and and
industrial science and both both
ecosystems have to be healthy and one
could argue that because of the
structure of academic funding right now
and also the dearth of funding in
certain areas it's not healthy and so
the people in industry I think make use
of discoveries that companies would not
be able to justify the time or the
expense of making that academia may you
know these discoveries are made in
academia but at the same time academia
cannot usually bring those discoveries
to the point where they are practically
useful and so I think that it's that's
this interplay that's important but just
my opinion thoughts by others but like
basically sounds like a talking my
medical stuff I come at it mostly from
an agricultural perspective and
environmental perspective I think I
agree medical stuff maybe is overfunded
agar
cultural stuff I would say is pretty
heavily underfunded in a pretty serious
way so this might just be a different of
industries that we're talking about here
difference in industries so do any of
you all have opinions about how we would
change you know how what would we do
with these all these PhDs I think we
need to bring the technicians and many
of the things we had in the past that
helped actually in science as opposed to
turning everyone into PhDs
if you look at the universities there is
no master's degree in very few
universities and even if you do get
master's degree it's very hard to find a
job because even the companies actually
turned the master's level positions into
phd's way in the past I had an interview
at one of the big corporations and they
said well you know there is not much
difference between masters level and PhD
in terms of salaries so there are so
many PhDs we can hire the PhDs is
opposed to masters but PhD does quite
different tanks compared to master level
training so I think we need to bring all
those levels back when we had the
healthy ecosystem and we shouldn't just
hired oh the US postdocs are expensive
let's import the PhDs from other
countries I think that should stop oh
you didn't really like the salary and
probably pay them proper salaries as
opposed to just keep them continuously
on a soft money position and give them
proper you know respect and I think one
other things should be added for the
postdocs this should not be called posta
they should be called their proper title
the doctor in that case it will do one
other thing as opposed to the lab had
his doctor and their scientist the
postdocs they're not trainees they're
not treated as trainees they're treated
when it comes to productivity as a
scientist they should also be called
Proctor's that's gonna make a big mind
shift because currently they are oh your
postdoc your you know underling you're
not as valuable as me but once they're
called doctors now everyone else is
gonna question why am I getting that low
but when you call them postdoc everyone
is okay with their salary but when you
call them doctors you're a doctor I'm a
doctor why am I getting there half or
quarter of your maybe 1/10 of your
salary so that's gonna create the
questions I think the postdocs should be
called their proper titles yeah I
totally agree that we shouldn't be
creating that many PhDs and right now
they're PhD level people are working
lattic work just because there's just
not enough jobs for phd's so so that's
one thing and then when you are in in
graduate school I think something that
does not get encouraged is exploring
other opportunities so I think we're all
get trained to work in an academic lab
that's at least when I was in school
that that was it that was what we were
trained for I don't remember meeting
anybody from any other industry even you
know biotech industry wasn't encouraged
at that time now it's different but you
know I think they the graduate schools
need to do a better job of you know
encouraging their students to explore
other options like getting into
government types of jobs politics you
know Public Health other other avenues
that they all use science as well like
environmental sciences that are you know
you're a biotech person but you are
working on the environmental issues so
all different kinds of avenues that the
PhD with with the education that they
can have they can bring a lot to the
table Christine so I actually think we
should keep giving people PhDs I love
the model that we pay people to do
science and become educated
but I also think that we as a society
should not view scientists as separate
like I think we should value scientists
who go do things that engage with
society like we should have public
school teachers who are doctors like we
should value that we should value
youtubers who do makeup tutorials who
are doctors who tell us the chemistry of
the skincare like we should actively
encourage people to do different things
during grad school so they don't feel
like they have to continue in this
so-called pipeline to be continued as a
scientist but rather there's this new
saying that people are using is like
stem is not a pipeline it's a prism
where you know everyone enters in one
wavelength but it separates and we can
have scientists in all sectors of
society and value them because I really
do think that there's a lot of stigma
and a little shame put on to scientists
who have doctorates or masters or
bachelors who do not continue doing
basic research or industrial research
etc I think we should one of the reasons
why we have such a disconnect between
the general public and science is
because we continue to uphold this
dichotomy between scientists and the
general public we have words that
scientists use to describe the rest of
the humans you know lay people whatever
like we need to actively you know mix
everyone together like I don't know why
we still feel like scientists should be
separated like we should have doctorates
everywhere you know like and not and not
shame people for or question a decision
to leave academia like we should not
value people in that way like I think we
would be so much better off if we had
people trained in rigorous scientific
analysis and and methods doing all sorts
of things whether that's even like
opening a bakery or running a daycare or
anything like that and this is
especially important because most of the
people who leave stem after receiving
PhD are women who have children so it's
like we have this entire way that we
devalue people who leave stem devalue
mothers and everything and the kind of
work that women do and I think we really
need to overhaul what we how we value
people who have different backgrounds
and stop-stop only valuing people who
continue in what we think they should be
doing
thanks that's really insightful much
appreciated so I'm going to have one
more question for the panelists and then
we'll probably we're probably still
under an hour but we'll have a few
questions but this last question sort of
gets to the heart of the topic of this
panel you know activism and science and
then politics and science and I'm
curious what each of you thinks about
the appropriateness is it an obligation
of scientists to call out people that
are pushing pseudoscience and do so
rigorously even at the risk of their own
reputations and you know I'm sure you
can all think of examples James Watson
who's a racist you know has not been
told to be not been told to shut up by
as many senior scientists as you'd think
should tell him to shut up that's one
example
Kary Mullis who actually invented PCR
just down the street here which was a
great invention is an aids denialists
people still invite him to events why
people who should know better who our
scientists so obviously you see where my
position is but but even you know even
when the anti-vaccine craze was really
big I remember having just just pretty
vicious arguments in fact it ruined some
friendly acquaintance ships and
friendships even with people who were
otherwise educated but not in in biology
and just thought that you know maybe you
know in one case you know some married
engineers they were not going to have
their kids vaccinated because of the
pseudoscience and you know I I felt
obliged to say no that has no basis in
reality at all and you know there's a
cost to that and I'm just curious each
if any of you have found yourselves in
the position of having to really try to
smack down something that you know is is
pseudo scientific where a scientist
who's has fringe opinions that they're
passing off as science and what is our
obligation
to do that or maybe not I mean where do
you where would you draw the line
so actually yeah so there's a lot of
clinics out there claiming that they're
gonna cure all diseases using stem cells
and and super expensive and they get
people's hopes high so that's something
that has come up in classes that I teach
and so we had enough of this discussion
that I decided to make it an assignment
for my students for some in one of my
classes that you know go do a little bit
of research on these clinics that claim
to be able to cure all diseases with
stem cells and then you know just write
a report just just so that they're aware
of that something like this exists and
as people who are studying biotechnology
they need to be aware of it so they can
tell others they can talk to their
parents who may be thinking of going to
these clinics or their you know
relatives and friends so yeah it is
important for us to speak about it and
try to educate others I agree with her
that education comes first
and that's why science education is
really really important it's important
at in elementary school middle school
high school throughout the education
system we can't really fix it overnight
because it's a belief pseudoscience
people who believe it's a belief it's
very difficult to change the belief but
creating awareness and education not
just in the college throughout the
education system is going to be able to
fix it I don't think it's gonna fix
everyone but at least creating awareness
like Kali said it's really important at
least that is on our side I think we can
do and maybe have a marketing person
they're very good at getting the message
and that comes with the marketing
pseudoscience too I think the question
posed is
very interesting cause used the word
call-out and I think some people should
some scientists should call out people
who you know profit off of pseudoscience
but they're also some scientists should
call in some people who should just
educate some people just inform some
people who should do it through empathy
some people who can do it through debate
I think not necessary every scientist
should engage with pseudoscience the
like in one prescribed way but we are
all people who can communicate with
other people in the way that's most
effective and there's a lot of really
great research being done currently to
understand how misinformation or
disinformation is propagated what the
intent is behind this information and I
think it is our collective
responsibility to combat these these
ideas that are patently false but
there's lots of different ways that we
can do it I think we have to be really
thoughtful about that because the whole
thing where if you call out someone and
go immediately on the offense they can
shut down and be defensive so you really
have to think about it as a two-way
communication street and and really do
our best as scientists not just to you
know provide a battery of facts but to
be empathetic and communicate as fellow
you know citizens as mother to mother
father to father kind of thing and I
think there's different rules that each
of us can play in terms of combating
this but it might be different for every
person so I hesitate to prescribe and
say that every scientist should do
something but I think that every
scientist should do something yeah I
think it's kind of hard to go last I
think but I I think there's a lot of
different types of pseudoscience and
that means there's a lot of different
types of people who talk about it and I
think that different approaches are
definitely merited I mean you have like
the the Vani Hari zuv the world food
babe who's just like a huckster who like
knows what she says is [ __ ] and she
sells books on it she makes money that
kind of stuff called out there's racists
there's like the alright you know people
like Ben Shapiro Jordan Peterson these
are people who are like maybe hucksters
maybe just dumb but definitely racist
and so like those kind of people can be
called out but there are definitely
people who
who I have to interact with a lot who
delve into pseudoscience and I think
that their perspectives are kind of not
being like understood from their point
of view so like for example I do a bunch
of work with like the burden I've had
been before I got too busy I don't want
to pretend I'm a big political activist
anymore but like eco socialist caucus in
the SF GSA in the city talking a lot
about like agricultural things and
environmental issues and so a group came
to us that was mostly an indigenous
group and they were talking to us about
like the cause that they were working on
and they were trying to get basically a
GMO crop banned and like these are not
hucksters these are not racists these
are people who have had a really really
long history of being [ __ ] over and
who like deserve to be heard and so like
when scientists come to these people and
they start saying things that aren't
right and all we're doing is like
correcting their vocabulary and like
picking them on things that they've said
that are not scientific that's not
helpful
and so like these are people that really
I think can be spoken with but you
really do need to let them know that you
understand where they're coming from I
mean like you definitely can't separate
for them I mean I would say for all of
us the idea of basically like their
inherent distrust of a genetically
modified crop and like the genocide of
their people much of which was
definitely based on like a denial of
food in a lot of different situations
and like the American governments like
sort of programs where basically we send
them these food in like little boxes
because we've taken all of their land
from them all of their assets obviously
everything shoved them into the middle
of the desert and then give them these
little food boxes that like suck and are
nutritionally deficient and then we're
trying to sell them other food and
they're like obviously distrustful of
that that makes total sense and like
yeah the fear of GMO is unfounded but
their fear of Americans is not and so
like I really think it's important for
scientists in particular and science
communicators to sort of learn a bit of
the language there and sort of learned
the place that you're coming into
especially people like me to be able to
talk about it in their language and
there's tons of times there have been in
like a far-left organizing situation
where someone has said something anti
GMO and I'm just like because I like can
sort of frame it in this way and be like
yes definitely you know like monsanto
generated Agent Orange
that was a like human rights disaster
and what they did to Vietnam is a war
crime like and being able to talk about
the issues that they know about and talk
to them in the language that like they
actually use to discuss issues that are
definitely real you can gain a lot more
trust and actually get people to be
convinced away from these sort of pseudo
scientific ideas when you convince them
that you're on the same side and but
first you need to genuinely be on the
same side you can't just parrot the
language and so I think it's really
important to learn the vocabulary not
with the era of teaching but first with
the with the idea of understanding and
then eventually when you feel you've
understood then you can engage in a
conversation and I wouldn't even say
that I'm 100% good at that there's
definitely times where I've been bad at
that yeah all right we want to be
respectful of time I think we can
probably open it up to questions for our
panelists and we don't have any roving
mics so I'll just you know hand the mic
off to whoever has a question so is
there anything that any of you would
like to hear our our great panelists
talked about we're yeah oh you don't
have questions okay two questions total
okay thank you so I think most of us are
scientists here and we I think I don't
want to speak for everyone but we tend
to gravitate towards evidence based in
fact based kind of analyses of a
situation and I'd like to ask our panel
how do you respond to when these sort of
evidence-based approaches don't seem
very effective and say the political
sphere and on the one hand how can we
incorporate other types of approaches
that might have a broader appeal and on
the other hand you know how to overcome
or should we overcome this resistance to
an evidence-based approach and I
personally liked Chris
what you said about having to approach
people with empathy and like what you
said about understanding people's
perspective before jumping in with with
the facts as it were thanks that's a
great question who wants to start so
I'll speak answer this question from a
little bit from experience and a little
bit from what people have done research
on particularly with people who are anti
VAX I think that is especially a
population where we need to understand
where these parents usually are coming
from they truly want what is best for
their children but they don't know
necessarily the science behind how
vaccines work to them it really is just
a needle administered by a doctor who is
really busy who doesn't really have the
time maybe to listen to all their
concerns and to them this is science
right they have seen a lot of evidence
online in their parenting groups or
whatever of correlation that symptoms
for disease or disorders like autism
emerged sometimes hours after a dose or
a routine vaccine and so to them this is
science right like this is basic science
you you observe an event and you
correlate it with what seems to be an
outstanding precipitating factor and
because babies get so many vaccines
early on in life right around the time
that we see a lot of symptoms emerge for
for life-altering disorders
this is science to them like this is I
know we like as scientists learned that
immediately a correlation is not
causation but for someone who does not
have a lot of experience doing
controlled experiments and even just in
human research like the best we can get
a lot of times is correlation so when
you cite a paper to them that is not the
same thing as them seeing you know their
cousin's child have a seizure three
hours after visiting the doctor so I
think we definitely need to understand
where these parents are coming from and
even ask them about their experiences
like why where did you get this idea
where did you learn this information and
be
a trusted source to them and not like
you know yell down from the ivory tower
but really understand like this fear
that they have that something that
they're going to give to their child
whether a bunch of experts recommend it
or not is going to harm their child I
think that's you know their motivation
number one and and really talk to them
from there as someone who also cares
deeply about their child and then
answering their questions so instead of
just giving people a list of facts like
common myths like ask them like what
questions do you have like can I just
sit down with you and explain to you the
immune system and like how vaccines work
how antibodies work like can we just
have a discussion about this and I know
that there's actually a friend of mine
who's a chemist her brother recently had
a baby and he was not gonna vaccinate
but what changed his mind was her
suggestion to do a little bit more
research and then a Netflix Bill Nighy
episode so like as much as some of us
scientists don't really love Bill Nye
the communication that works that
resonates with people like often does
come from a trusted source and a lot of
people who are AR age now view Bill Nye
as a trusted source cuz he was in our
classrooms telling us about momentum
talk about all this stuff so I think
trust might be the number one thing and
we are trained to trust citations and
experiments and controlled studies but a
lot of people don't have this science
education this training to trust just
words on a paper and they they believe
what they can see and they believe what
people say that they know truly have a
vested interest in the Wellness of them
and their children I would also add to
that that you know facts are great and I
have a science background actually I'm
the only person here doesn't have a PhD
and also isn't trying to get one so
probably the least science background
but facts are good but I think it's
important to also listen to emotions and
to even use that sometimes in your
messaging you can't like there's a lot
of there's actually a lot of evidence
and this is a little ironic that facts
don't convince people and that telling
people stats doesn't convince them and
so I think it's a little
while that is scientists people who base
ourselves on evidence we then try and
use facts when we know that's a lot of
people nod but that doesn't work so like
why do we keep doing that I think you
should use a little bit of emotion in
that and sort of make it something
that's very personal for people like
when I really talk about the antibac
stuff and I do know some hints evac
series being in the political circles
that I'm in I talk about them like hey
like you know someone in my really close
nuclear family is diagnosed autistic
like do you think it'd be better if he
was dead like this is a really personal
thing for me like when you're talking
about this you're saying it's better to
be dead than autistic that's a pretty
strong thing I mean I also have a good
friend who does a lot in terms of like
autistic activism and one of the things
that this person says which is really
awesome I think everyone in this room if
you haven't you should go online and
look at what the symptoms of autism are
you probably take a lot of the boxes
like and this isn't just because it's a
room of scientists autism is a very a
very broad thing like I take a lot of
the boxes for autism and I know that's
sort of like telling on myself but like
I think a lot of people do and this
person who does this advocacy basically
what they're saying is like pretty much
everyone is autistic one way or another
it's a very broad range of symptoms that
honestly a lot of them don't have a lot
to do with each other and to people who
have autism have nothing to do with each
other so it's like talk to people about
that about like hey maybe we're all
autistic maybe I'm autistic maybe autism
isn't 100% real a lot of the time and
like maybe it's over diagnosed a lot of
people have people in their family that
are autistic and like to say that being
dead is better is like a pretty strong
thing to say I would say did we address
your question somewhat so we we have one
more quiet time for one more question
and then after this there will be
mingling and curated conversation as it
were so there's plenty of time to talk
but I saw a hand so my question has to
do with the accessibility of science so
a friend of mine recently he was not a
scientist
he wanted to learn about nutrition and
so he he sometimes like go look at
journals and wonder who pays the $30 to
read the papers he paid $30 to read some
random nutrition articles and not a
trained scientist so he didn't wouldn't
didn't know like you know when you read
a scientific paper not all of it is
exactly facts right there just like
somebody's ideas and so he asked me
because I was making fun of him and he
asked me he was like well what am I
supposed to do if I want to learn about
nutrition read like primarily literature
and I don't want to read any sort of
secondary literature that's gonna
already like piecemeal where where the
actual data comes from I actually had no
answer for him
and I'm wondering sort of what the panel
thinks about that so people just the
general public that a don't have access
to all of the scientific journals that
we do with scientists but B also Canada
even if they did have access can
necessarily don't can't distinguish
between good science and bad science and
also with nutrition it's very difficult
to do so any opinions in that realm how
can I answer my friends question please
okay so at least this is true for UC
Berkeley but the UC Berkeley University
Libraries are also public libraries so
your friend can literally go go into the
campus libraries and ask help from a
librarian to also number one get the
primary research articles for free and
then also just for some help on parsing
through that literature so there are
some great resources where scientists
are doing some writing that is more
accessible particularly through this
group called massive science so they do
a lot of stuff but they're there
topics range everything from GMOs to
psychedelics to nutrition and they're
only building up so they don't have a
great archive yet but I would recommend
that your friend tried to find like even
if they find like a research article
primary research article they're
interested in to find if there's a
university press release or anything
like that where the information is free
and often the the author's have
some sort of role in writing up that
press release and try to at least make
sure it's not over like exaggerated in
terms of the claims because they do know
that people outside of the immediate
field are going to be reading it so
those are the two main things I suppose
I would recommend however I acknowledge
like it is completely terrible out there
for anyone who does want to do primary
research reading and this is super true
for parents who have children who are
suffering from different disorders they
try to read a lot of primary literature
and they often pay hundreds of dollars
in these fees just to try to learn about
new clinical trials and things that are
going on so that I think it is slowly
happening that we will have open access
primary literature pretty soon the use
of the entire UC system just terminated
a huge like billion something dollar
contract with Elsevier so I think this
hopefully you know will no longer be an
issue like 20 years in the future but
right now yeah it's it's pretty terrible
so thank you for the question another
good source is of course plus one so
plus one is an online you know and then
the papers are all free also in PubMed
you know he you know you search there
are some some of the articles are free
not all but some of them are free but
yeah I mean there are a lot of resources
universities are great so if you find
someone a scientist who is actually
doing work on that field just go to
their website and see what they have
there and then maybe you can even
arrange a little informational interview
where the person who's actually doing
the work so there are some resources but
I do agree it's it's difficult for
someone who's not in science so so to
comment on a few different issues I
think that that as Kristine noted there
is a move towards publicly funded
research being absolutely publicly
accessible now that doesn't help with
the interpretation but that's probably
coming I mean I don't understand how
research that gets one dollar of the
people's money should be behind a
paywall and hopefully one of these
we can get Randy Schekman here who
believes in an open access public
publishing and as a Nobel laureate and
found a tee life a journal that that is
open access that's a really important
issue but in terms of like trying to
parse the meaning and even in complex
fields there's just this deluge of
papers and the people who've been in the
field a long time I mean even from even
biology PhDs have trouble parsing the
literature of a new field and when we
have to pivot to a new field in our in
our work sometimes it takes a long time
just to figure out what lines of
research are deprecated and which are
are not because most of the deprecated
research isn't retracted it's just you
know buried under the pile of more
recent literature and so there's
actually there might be some uses for
machine learning in helping to
understand scientific literature of
course it's early days but that's one
natural thing that could help everyone
including scientists because it's too
much to assimilate but there is another
thing and I think that it gets to the
responsibility of people who are
receiving advanced training or education
depending on how you look at it in the
sciences you know PhD is the D is is doc
tiss which is Latin for teacher and in
the end of the day PhDs have the
obligation to help teach people their
subject matter at a level that rises to
philosophy and so if that means helping
a member of the public understand their
field and best the best understanding of
their field they should take the time
when they can to do that now what does
it look like for your friend well I
think one thing is to reach out to
nonprofit subject area associations so
maybe an association having to do with
the you know a disease or disorder that
you're interested in that is is not
funded by a commercial interest often
that's a good starting place and people
working in the office there can make
referrals and and and often help
summarize the literature but also yes
you could go to university websites and
reach out to subject area experts
themselves now they're going to be Dell
you they have a deluge of work and
emails but sometimes they will respond
and especially I think all of us should
try to respond to help people understand
our fields because the you know the
privilege if it is a privilege of having
a PhD is that you have to teach in my
view
fortunately scientists are most of them
most of us do like to talk about our
work and and and educate others so I
have my students do informational
interviews all the time and you'd be so
surprised at how many responses they get
you know at first they're all scared oh
I'm gonna email this complete stranger
they're not gonna read my email but
you'll be surprised they all reply and
all happy and I tell them you know your
your interview should not take more than
half an hour there these are busy people
but a lot of them come back and say oh
we talk for two hours I'm like that's
great
so yeah people are usually happy to talk
about their work I just want to add one
thing is if your friend or anybody
usually just emails that one of the
authors to the paper they'll just send
the PDF for free so that's usually just
like step number one yeah just to read
it into the record because that was a
really good way I actually wanted to say
that for the past five minutes yeah the
other thing you can do is ask a
scientist who's at a university like you
said and just be like hey can you get
this paper for me like if your friend is
your friend and you are a scientist or
if they know other scientists you can
get it for them for free but yeah I do
that all the time and I know that we're
like a pub like a private company and we
should be paying people for their work
but scientists don't get paid when you
buy the papers so it's like just ask the
scientists they'll give it to you for
free it works it's worked every time
I've done it and I've done it a lot oh
sure of course
I think your question gets to the heart
of a really important aspect of what
we're working on doing here and that's
integration right a lot of molecular but
molecular biology a lot of nutrition
information a lot of scientific
experimentation is all focused on
reductionism right drilling down into
that one specific aspect that you're
studying and focusing on how that
particular aspect changed in that
particular way results in whatever your
data generates right but bringing that
reductionist perspective out into an
integrated understanding of what does
the rest of the body of linear
literature tell us right what is this
how is this applicable to you personally
to this industry to this aspect of
existence that sort of conversion from
reductionist perspective to integrated
perspective is a really important one
and I think that's why there's so many
comments and thinking and how do we go
about facilitating this back and forth
between the curious and the researchers
because it's not just the researchers
that are dispensing information it's the
curious that are provoking new questions
right and I think that's a really
critical part and maybe something
science doesn't always do a good job of
encouraging or welcoming or or bringing
into the folds so I really appreciate
you asking this question and in addition
to you all of these answers where the
researchers really do want to talk about
what they do and how they do it and why
it's interesting and probably a lot of
unrelated things that don't actually get
to your friends question right oh I
think there also needs to be a
recognition that there's a need for
people who synthesize there's a need for
people who bring together different
aspects in different areas of research
and in application to provide this
cohesive picture because it's probably
not going to come from that one specific
basic research scientist who is really
focused on the thing that they are
really good at it's probably gonna come
from outside from someone who has main
connections in other fields who is
thinking a little bit more broadly about
what does it mean that I'm asking this
question and what does it mean that this
particular result showed up here right
so I'll make sure that by okay
survey tweets out a there's a data
scientist who actually does a really
good job of compiling nutritional
information in a way that makes sense
where the total number of studies on a
particular let's call it an ingredient
and how it relates to a specific
condition is all captured in one graph
in circles and different sizes and
colors and it's it's brilliant but that
is its own specialized field of study
and right now basic research doesn't do
so well in integrating that and I think
we could build a lot more connections
there so thank you so much for letting
me jump in very insightful and and I
actually think that in many ways you
sort of summed up the purpose of the
evening which is to address some topics
ones that you maybe don't always think
of in the context of science and
scientists which is activism and also to
make unexpected connections between the
housing crisis and people's ability to
be creative and issues in education
industry versus academia how do we do it
more fairly what what roles do
scientists have in the world of activism
and politics and so I'd like to thank
all the panelists who just did a
wonderful job and we're so excited to
have you here today and I'd like to
thank the audience the great questions
and also invite all of you to to mingle
we do have a rule though we do not want
people to be talking about what the
president tweeted today or some
outrageous thing that happened in
Hollywood you know lits yen who's in the
back has some mind Muse papers and these
are quotations that help set the stage
for the conversation and did you want to
explain that yeah so no small talk and
talk about your deepest longing your
drive and networking is about
expectation like why networking is no
circular logic is not networking so you
can mingoes
jp's and score the purpose of networking
is to really to bring you together those
people who can help you to accomplish
something that you
your privilege could not so I really
love the idea of half a cake you should
sell half a cake just be honest about it
and so it is it's not like fairness but
the thing is like don't be afraid of
speaking about like half-baked ideas and
don't be afraid of us speaking of your
needs and your vulnerabilities and like
what kind of a path that you you you
want what kind of resource that you want
and has an expectation that you will
find a community in the family that will
bring you to your next stage of your
your new chapter so this is my my advice
which is no small talk and talk about
something that you've don't talk about
your day job and embrace yourself and
discover your true self together and
also then I have some print out that
will help you do networking you can talk
about some of the quote that you like
and but you don't have to or you can
talk about other things but I really
like the things I select so a little
self congratulatory but thank you thanks
Jenn and so let's let's build this
community and thanks for coming everyone
oh and and I do have a shout-out to Alan
and simulation podcast so they have done
the AV tonight this panel and question
and answers but not the happy hour will
be broadcast or will be available online
and you really tomorrow and you should
really listen to have a look at
simulation livestream it's it has
hundreds of really interesting
interviews and Alan has curated all
these really cool people and groups of
people and and many different ideas so I
encourage you to have a look at what
he's done because it's it's pretty
magnificent and thanks again Alan much
appreciated so good night everyone
[Applause]